Shocked. Shocked. Shame on you Muslim
men. You have become cowards and simps.
Shame on you guys, bro. YOU'RE JIGGLING
YOUR WIFE IN FRONT OF MEN, BRO. Is this
what you've become? They showcasing
their wife, bro. Casually their wife's
blurring the husband out, man.
This is onem video. If you care about
the dunya more than skip it. By one
donation, you're going to help 1.8
million people in need. 551,000 people
who have been fed through the emergency
food aid. You are going to be sponsoring
4,200 orphans. You will be helping
25,000 people in Gaza. You'll be helping
123,000 people to be fed through our
Kmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one Umah 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund. So that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on your decision is yours. The
link is there. Donate now. Asalam
alaikum to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. I know a lot of people watch
this uh video or think um like I I I
really don't understand like certain
people they come and say you know what
oh you know brother Ali you know why do
you have to talk about this etc drama
this that and I'm just like man do you
not see where we are heading as an um
like genuinely does it not concern you
that there are men
Muslim men
fullbuilt Muslim men with a beard
and they are showcasing their wives and
it's come to the point where subhan
Allah the women are blurring their
husbands out and showing their self
and
I blame the men like I look at this and
I say hold on a second bro like before I
play you guys this video that's
absolutely shocking and I swap the rub
of the caba I was just on Instagram
finished the live just filming a video
here about us taking over Scotland just
about to go home just scrolling on
Instagram and I came across this and I
was like what the hell like forget that.
What shocked me was, you know, you see,
you know, she's there dancing. You could
just scroll past and be like, what the
hell? I would be like, yeah. And then in
the corner, I see this man and I'm
thinking, who is this man? Like, is this
AI? What is this? I go to their profile.
This is a man, a Muslim man married. And
that's his wife. And his wife is
dancing.
His wife is dancing
to the men on social media and I'm just
like
I'm just trying to understand brother I
have
for your wife. She's not my wife. She's
my sister in Islam. I have protective
jealousy over her and I'm angry at what
you're doing when it should be you. Bro,
I went to the comments. It made me even
more angry. Bro, you've got there for
content. your wife in your hand like
this, like she's some kind of object in
your hand. Like you're holding her like
she's some kind of an object. She's
there dancing, bro. Shaking her body.
Well, like I don't even want to say it.
Shaking her body. Dancing.
Yes. Some can even deem it seductive or
whatever. Yeah. And you're just there
making content.
I'm absolutely
the comments, bro. If I saw the
comments, I would want to die. Imagine
my wife. Alhamdulillah. Yes. That
doesn't want to be seen on social media.
Alhamdulillah. Yes. Okay. That's a
choice. Not even me. Me personally, I
would not allow it. Period. No way in
hell. Abadan. No way. Yes. I'm going to
let my wife be in public. And I'm going
to get my wife to dance, move her body,
move her hips, move her upper body,
whatever. her her waist, her thigh, her
body, dancing in a whatever way to a
song. And as her husband, and I'm the
one who's doing the camera, the work,
the camera work.
[snorts]
Do you want to read the comments? Watch
the video, guys. Watch the video. But
and then come look at the comments.
Look at the comments. Look at look at
this. Wii wahi, brother. Wai, I'm
genuinely saying this out of concern. My
sister, my brother. Wahi.
Somebody goes, "Bro, brother, stop
jiggling your wife for us.
Stop jiggling your wife for us, bro.
Mashallah, our wife is gorgeous. Next
time, make sure she turns around a few
times and wears open to toe heels." You
deserve it, bro. You deserve it, bro.
With all your respect. How do you feel
about us looking at her? Bro, men are
visual creatures. Men are visual
creatures. Yes, men have high sex drive.
Bro, men get turned on by this how Allah
has created us. That's why we should be
lowering our gaze. But the reality is
there. The prophetam when he walked out,
he happened to see a woman and he a
desire hit his heart. He went back to
his wife and had intimacy with her. This
is our reality. This is how men are
created. That's the reason why Allah has
told us to lower the gates and told the
woman to dress up. No. If it was only us
lowering the gates, then one woman could
walk around naked. Yes. And then if it
was about just woman just covering up,
then we can look where we want cuz
there's nothing to see. No, we both have
to do our work. Unless you're feminist
who blame you for it and you're a
barbarism and hiddenism and whatever you
are. How dare how dare you be created
like that? How did Allah create you like
that? Allah created like that and put
protocols in place. Yes. Okay. There's a
reason why men and women cannot be
alone. Where can why cannot be friends?
Look at that wall. Look at this.
Somebody what a stupid comment l all
these men in the comments who hate women
existing without their permission. How
is that hating a woman? telling a man to
have protective jealousy and sometimes I
s these social influences saying coming
and saying yeah yeah yeah thank you
brother for showing us your wife next
time do this and I think like bro why
you talking like that I don't blame them
I don't blame them look at what you are
doing bro you are showcasing your wife
like a trophy like these kufar men do
when they was in bikini and mini skirt
they're like yeah every man checking
their w can you imagine checking your
wife in a bikini bro she's in her
underpants and men can see everything
you can
Everything you can see except she's not
fully naked. They can see. They know her
body shape. They know her waist. They
know what she looks like in a bikini.
Bikini though. What a low life we have
become. Subhan Allah. That sexually
objectification your wife like she's a
trophy in Islam. We protect women. Have
honor and dignity. Bro, she's covered up
and she's dancing, jiggling, whatever.
And you're there like, you know, yeah,
I've got this, etc. Walli, brother. I I
don't know what to say to you.
Come to your senses, bro. My dear
sister. I And I blame the men. If you
had the leadership roles, if you had the
respect and this, can you imagine who
matters? Social media. Bro, he imagine
on the day of judgment, you want to
stand in front of Allah. The prophetam
said a man came a companion. He said, if
I see my wife, another man or something
like that, he goes, he will get the end
of my sword. He said, "You think he's I
have more over the Muslim folk and Allah
has more for the Muslim woman than this
man." Subhan Allah. Look at this. Look,
alhamdulillah, there's some levelheaded
sisters.
Fear Allah and be a man. Yes. Wall, what
kind of a husband and man are you that
you are getting your wife to and dance?
Bro, where is your where is your shame?
Wai, what have we come down to, man? And
I will call this out till the day I die.
Bro, come. Like I said before, you know,
let's do the whole situation a couple of
months ago. Come for my family. Wall,
you're not going to stop me. Wall. Come
for my daughters, my children, my baby,
my my newborn, whoever you want. Come.
I'm never going to stop calling out. And
I want to be called out myself if I'm
wrong as well. I'm never going to stop
calling these kind of men and corrupt
women. Never ever I'm going to stop. as
long as I live. If Allah subh wiggles
will inshallah, I'm going to call out
this is evil. This is you there sexually
objectifying a woman to the masses of
men, bro. And they're commenting and
saying, "Yeah, get your wife to jiggle
next time and do this. I would rather
die, bro. Can you imagine, bro? Put my
wife, Subhan Allah, my wife doesn't even
want her voice to be heard, bro." Okay?
And I'm not trying to act like a holy
than thou. Yes, I respect my wife that
she's like, "No, no, I don't want none
of that." Yes. And I would never allow
that. Subhan Allah.
I am very happy that that they were
called out on this video. You're very
proud of all the comments. Yeah. Same.
Same. And look look what people say. Our
wife can dance. M. Look, they're
claiming is that their it's their wife.
This this haram. You should not say
that. It's not your wife. Yeah. This
haram to be careful what what you're
saying. Thanks for sharing your wife's
shake shaky goods with us. Someone in
the comments said he had bones from
Look at this. Look at this. Look at
this. Look at this. Bro, look. Look. Do
you think you know what men will do?
Well, there are men out there. Yeah,
this is disgusting. I'm telling you,
they would they would go and fulfill
their desires by looking at this video.
Brother, brother, brother. And Allah is
going to question you, bro. And I blame
you men. I don't want to carry on with
this. Yeah. W I blame you men. You men
have become cowards. You have become the
biggest sims. And we know the biggest
sim who lives in Bradford. I don't know
how he looks at his wife in his face.
Yeah. Well, the biggest simp coward I've
seen in my life. Alhamdulillah. Allah
has exposed him as Bat Jahil.
Alhamdulillah. Yes. The cow who couldn't
even come face to face. I don't know how
he I don't know how he meets his fight.
I don't know how he goes back to his
wife. His wife's looking at him thinking
about what kind of a you are, bro.
My man called you out. You could have
meet him. You s, bro. That's what
you are. And there are simps like him.
He was saying my wife didn't give me
permission. That's what he told me.
Subhan Allah. Just imagine,
bro, you were men have become cowards,
bro. So much so that woman, bro, can you
imagine for social media and likes and
this stuff, she's jiggling jiggling for
the people. I'm just frustrated. I don't
even know what I'm talking about. I've
my my brain is gone. I'm even I'm just
repeating the same thing over and over
again. The first time in a video I'm
doing this. I don't know what to say.
Fear Allah, bro. You're going to watch
this video, man. Fear Allah, man.
Brother, how are you letting your wife
jiggle and dance in front of people,
bro? And that clothing is tight clothing
with all your respect. Yes. And she's
dancing in habibi. Please come to your
senses. Is it worthful views, bro?
Views. Wah. This a sign from Allah.
Allah is humiliating, bro. That's
humiliation.
May Allah fix affairs, bro. That's what
I'm going to say. May Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala fix our affairs cuz I do not know
what to say, bro. Shocked. Shocked.
Shame on you, Muslim men. You have
become cowards and simps. Shame on you
guys, bro. YOU'RE JIGGLING YOUR WIFE IN
FRONT OF MEN, BRO. You shameless
cowards, man. Is this what you've
become?
And other people as well.
They showcasing their wife, bro.
casually. Their wife's blurring the
husband out, man while she's in tight
clothing. You can see everything, but
she's blurring her husband out. Don't
look at my husband. She's got more, bro.
I'm I'm going to say something I'm going
to regret, guys. May Allah protect us.
This is one video. If you care about the
more than skip it by one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who've been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000 people
to be fed through our Kmani program. You
will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one um 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on your makama. The decision is
yours. The link is there. Donate now.